okay I got a ton of emails tweets and
YouTube comments yesterday when we
covered Donald Trump getting food at
mar-a-lago and this viral picture that
we have after he declared a national
emergency
I said he's at the omelet station and a
lot of people said David that's not how
it's pronounced one of those people was
the egg man who we haven't heard from
for a while
here's what the egg man said hi I'm Paul
talk today's English is my second
language death it's pronounced omelet
not omelet it does not have three
syllables in it
please look I don't mean to criticize
you but I just want you to tell me I'm
not the only one who corrected you on
that instead of twice a mole it's just
if you're not spirit say once and then
run away from the mic and then wait till
tomorrow figure out I say don't double
down anyway Salaam brother I'm gonna go
get a bacon egg and cheese omelet for
breakfast yeah okay um thank you Eggman
Shalom to you I uh this is how I've
always said it and I think it may be
because the word is really a French word
and in Argentina in Spanish it's
basically the French pronunciation so I
guess is so is do you say omelette I it
would just never occurred to say it to
me that way Pat you know as a vegan I
think I'm going to stay out of this
altogether I don't eat omelets I don't
know how to pronounce omelette either
one works for me
I will I I admit this is not a high
priority for me to correct I made an
effort to fully understand fewer verses
less I made an effort to say Nevada and
Hawaii as opposed to Nevada and Hawaii
and that's it i think i'm gonna continue
saying omelet and i love it
okay we've got a great bonus show for
you today i'm out of time but it's a
good one become a member become a patron
much more show coming up today if you
want it but you've got to listen to it
or watch it on the bonus show